the Final Fantasy 7 remake features some
truly impressive summon animations but
none are quite as mesmerizing as the
final you unlock in the game Bahamut
before you claim that prize though you
have to put in some serious work here's
our guide on how to unlock Final Fantasy
7 remake s-- most powerful summon you
should know that the key to getting new
powerful materia in Final Fantasy 7
remake is Chadli a side character you'll
find in chapter 3 who gives you battle
Intel assignments to complete when
fighting enemies knocking out chad lays
objectives allows him to create new
materia
the most time-consuming of these are
unlocking every weapon ability with each
character and mastering all 20 of the
green magic materials in the game some
of these materials specifically revive
require a huge grind to complete so if
you can be sure to pair it with the AP
up support materia which gives you a
hundred percent increase to earning AP
as soon as you can after you complete
all other battle Intel objectives you'll
unlock chad lee's final challenge waha
moot defeat the summon and you'll get
the baharlou to summon materia but it's
a tough fight to get it by Hammoud is
one of the toughest bosses in the game
it's fast and aggressive with a number
of powerful abilities that hit very very
hard its crowning lethal move is Mega
Flare a final attack that will hit all
of your characters with so much damage
that it'll likely wipe them out even at
full health and even if your leveled all
the way up to 50 having the highest
defense you can is key to dealing with
waha moot and you'll want to rely on God
when he comes at you with attacks like
his claw slashes or his spinning charge
attack you won't avoid most of these
because baha moot is so huge so get used
to blocking with cloud punisher mode
will allow you to get in some
counter-attacks so you're not just
getting pummeled while defending against
other attacks is important you have to
start Barham loot from using Mega Flare
at all costs if you want to win the
fight you'll know who's getting ready to
use this massive attack when he starts
to count
down he starts at five and when he gets
past one he'll almost immediately wipe
out your whole team you can stop that
from happening however by staggering him
building by stagger meat it should be
your primary focus throughout the fight
and guide all your loadout and attack
decisions your battle strategy is to
block with a big attacks environment
while closing in and constantly wailing
on him with anything that can drive up
to the stagger meter we primarily
utilized ki Fateh for this job
while issuing orders to cloud and Barret
to keep up the pressure or to heal
teammates when you can use ATP abilities
10 towards clouds focus thrust Barrett's
focus shot and tifa's focus strike to
push up Barham oops stagger meter even
more you'll also want to spend some time
in the corn AO Coliseum in chapter 14
where you can earn the ascension dolphin
flurry and catastrophe Limit Breaks for
completing the individual character vs.
wild animals fights equipment seems to
be the difference so make sure you've
got your team set up for I attack damage
and defense if you want to survive stick
to the staggered strategy and Baja Moot
should be yours in no time
[Music]